unidentified gunman shot dead six polio
workers in eastern afghanistan on
tuesday
during a polio vaccination drive police
in the province of nangarhar
blamed the taliban for the attacks the
group has denied responsibility
the latest killings come just two months
after three female polio workers
were killed in the provincial capital
jalalabad also
during a polio vaccination drive the
islamic state group claimed
responsibility for that killing
afghanistan is one of only two countries
in the world which has yet to eradicate
polio
its neighbor pakistan is the other
a life cut short while trying to save
others
this polio worker has become another
tragic statistic
in the war-torn country
the government hires vaccinators but
cannot protect them vaccinators receive
only four dollars a day
i lost my brother what should i do with
this government now
the wounded now fight for their lives in
hospital
police say it was a coordinated attack
the vaccination teams were watched
and hunted gunned down in three
different locations
over two hours
today we started work at eight o'clock
in the morning
after half an hour i heard the sound of
firing
i wasn't near the victims at the time
but then i ran to them
and saw they were dead and lying on the
ground i didn't see the attackers
polio has yet to be eradicated in
afghanistan
many people are suspicious of vaccines
religious extremists believe they're a
western tool
to sterilize muslim children or collect
intelligence
after the attacks in nungah a four-day
vaccination drive
meant to reach more than 9 million
children has been called off
instead there will be funeral
preparations
and mourning for the victims their work
left
undone
joining me for more now from kabul is
godwin mindra unicef's deputy chief for
polio immunization in afghanistan mr
mindra welcome
why are polio workers being attacked in
afghanistan
thank you for having me uh on this
interview and
and greetings from sunny afghanistan
first of all
i would like to what's our condolences
to
the frontline workers that we lost
yesterday
um in five coordinated attacks
um we had um
six lives lost and four were injured
um this uh life that we have
unnecessarily lost
um so we condole with the families uh
the relatives and their and their close
siblings
um and for the program too we are we're
saddened for this
senseless loss of life why why
they are targeted um
i cannot tell but i would like to to
to say that the safety and security of
our frontline workers
is a it's it's the priority of the
program
we would like our vaccinators our social
mobilizers to go out there
and interact and vaccinate children in a
very safe environment
but this is not the first time sir sorry
to cut too short but this is not the
first time that
vaccinators are being targeted in fact
three female vaccinators were killed in
march itself
it's true yes um in march we lost
three females to similar attacks
in the same in the same region um
and and it has happened again yesterday
we're saddened by all this happening
but we we still believe that it's
important to get
vaccinators out there to vaccinate
children in a very safe environment
without being targeted but surely
you all must be looking at why this
keeps happening because
surely that needs to determine how you
move ahead with this program
that's correct and uh that's why from
march to
to to date we have been working with the
government and and
partners were involved in the
vaccination of children
to first of all understand why three
females were attacked
uh and killed in uh in in march
and we are working with the government
uh
in the same way today and and in the
future to make sure that uh
vaccinators go out there safely so for
yesterday's uh
incidents we we are working with the
government to understand
why vaccinators are targeted why we lost
lives yesterday so this is an ongoing
investigation
we will probably get to the roots of
this after
the government and the security forces
understand the result for these attacks
how is this impacting how are these
killings impacting the polio drive in
afghanistan
it is sad to see lives lost
when people are out there to do the good
that they are supposed to deliver
especially when they're out there to
deliver vaccinations that would protect
children
uh from crippling disease like polio and
other
vaccine preventable diseases so it's uh
it's demoralizing it's uh
it it uh it affects
the the energies the momentum that we
have developed so far
um to reduce uh the vulnerabilities uh
that this country experiences for polio
vitas
to children godwin mindra speaking to us
from kabul thank you so much for joining
us sir
thank you thank you for having me
you